hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're in game
10 of our coverage the 1972 World Chess
Championship between Bobby Fischer and
Betty Spassky deemed the match of the
century up until this point Bobby
Fischer holds a two-game advantage but
he Spassky hasn't even won a game since
game number two when Bobby Fischer
didn't even show up so but he's basking
one game one and two since then Bobby
Fischer has rattled off four wins and
then they've drawn some here and there
so in game 10 Bobby Fischer's going to
be looking to extend that lead but he's
fast he is going to be looking to get
back on the horse and at least draw with
the black pieces definitely does not
want to go down three games you can come
up with a pretty creative defense and
get a victory that would also be good as
well so we'll start out Bobby Fischer
pawn to e4 always like to be very
aggressive pawn to e4 is favorite
opening pawn to e5 Knight f3 knight c6
Bishop to b5 getting into the right
Lopez pray comment at this time
pawn to a6 key into the Morphy defense
Bishop back here a4 Knight to f6 both
sides just developing pieces castle on
the King side Bishop e7 getting ready to
castle on the King side as well
rooks at you one protecting the pawn on
e4 pawn to b5 forcing the bishop back
here to b3 pon d6 pawn c3 getting ready
to push forward on d4 these are sort of
the main lines in the right Lopez casts
on the King side pawn to h3 and this is
where we do kind of shift into a
variation we don't always see and that's
the Brier variation that's the knight
coming back to b8 this opens up the door
for the pawn to push forward to c5 if
like ever wants to counter-attack on the
Queen side also allows him to later
bring his Knight to d7 to protect the
square in a 5 this is a very important
square in this opening what's
interesting is this really came to be
very popular in the 1960s brought about
by buddy Spassky he knows this opening
better than anyone so you have Bobby
Fischer playing the white pieces a very
aggressive opening in the right Lopez
and then you have buddy's fast counting
playing the black pieces who knows this
defense better than anyone so we're
definitely going to have an exciting
match up today pawn here to d4 just
ready to attack the seer the board he
could have played a little quieter with
pawn to d3 that's just not Bobby Fischer
style pawn here to d4 and the Knight to
d7 as we talked about this
the square here on e5 Fisher continues
with night to d2 Bishop d7 just
continuing development putting more
pressure on the central squares with a
bishop attacking the square here on e4
a bishop back here to see to defending
the square a little bit more a rook to
e8 just getting involved into the center
of the board that's exactly what you
want to do then pawn up here to b4 miss
you're back here f8 and so black has a
few options if you wanted to he could
play Bishop to f8 as he did and then
open up the door for this rook here on
e8 to defend the square here on e5 but
he also could just been a little bit
more aggressive you could have said
let's start gobbling up material pawn
takes on d4 I will see a recapture pawn
to c5 really starting to attack on Queen
side after some exchange on board you
know pawn to e5 Bobby Fischer starting
to push on the Kings side over here we
can see pawn to c4 if we wanted to
after the knight moves it is under
attack right now but really starting to
attack on the Queen side and put some
pressure on Bobby Fischer but in the
game we saw Bishop to f8 opening up the
door for a rook to defend here on e5
upon to a4 so Bobby Fischer's yeah I can
attack on the King side but I'll go and
tack on the Queen side as well Knight to
b6 not doing too much after the pawn to
a5 it's just going to force the knight
back here to d7 Bishop to b2 just get
involved into the action Queen over here
b8 I don't know that this does too much
for birdie spassky's position it's not
really helping too much of his material
he could have even tried getting his
rook involved rook to c8 if he ever does
want to start to push forward pawn to c5
I think eventually should happen this is
just going to give him an extra defender
as he starts to push up the c-file buddy
decided to play Queen to b8 a rook to b1
just getting a little bit more active
and then pawn to c5 this is why I think
it makes total syncs to have your rook
here on c8 but he does not so alas pawn
takes on c5 a pawn takes now pawn takes
here on e5 Knight takes and then after
Knight takes we see the Queen come down
and so this is kind of what he had all
along the Queen takes here on e5 item
see a lot of attackers on the square
here on e4 part of it I just want to see
how many actual arrows I could get on
the screen I couldn't read more but this
is what I had on here for now so the
Queen rook Knight and Bishop so four
attackers on the square here on e4 right
now White has three defenders Bishop
Knight and rook so he has find a
creative way to actually defend this and
he does find a creative way if you kind
of look at and say okay well let's go to
get the Queen involved into the action
Queen to f3 is kind of weird after Queen
to f3 Bishop to d6 that's kind of
threatening this Queen over here to h2
that's going to be extremely bad pawn to
g3 trying to stop that pawn to c4 over
here just making sure there's no
shenanigans with the pond pushing
forward discovered attack from the
bishop onto the Queen here on e5 but
then you still see you know rook to e2
Bishop down here a c5 putting a lot of
pressure all of a sudden why it's kind
of playing defense that's not what he
wants to do so he found a pretty
creative way to it defendant that's pawn
here to c4 let's attack the biggest
piece which is kind of at the forefront
of this attack with the bishop here on
b2 so nice little attack from him Queen
to f4 there are still a lot of errors
but I'm not pointing them at the pond
right now but then we say okay let's go
ahead and start taking material off the
board if you're going to attack this
pawn I can't really defend it with too
much more so I'm just going to start
gobbling up material Bishop takes on f6
Queen takes pawn takes here on b5 rook
over here to d8 and this is a pretty
creative way to kind of attack this pond
right here the knight was defending it
instead of just having the bishop and
the rook attacking it says I'm going to
bring your rook over here your knight
can't move anywhere so nice little
variation right here Queen to c1 now the
knight can move if he wants to Queen
down here to c3 attacking both the rook
and the Queen are attacking and then
Knight up here to f3 but this is pretty
good move for pretty spassky's now he
can just come in and take this pawn on
a5 now Bobby Fischer plays what I
think's an incredible movie plays Bishop
to b3 if you look at material material
is equal
now but he could easily just take pawn
takes on a six makes a lot of sense
Bishop can recapture if he wants to this
seems fine seems low risk you'd be in
fine position but plays Bishop to b3 and
says I'll give up material if I need to
and that's exact what happened so pawn
takes on b5 but he has other things in
mind Queen to f4 attacking this pawn
here on f7 and so decides to play rook
to the seven to protect this I think he
maybe could have tried pawn to c4 I like
this a little bit better
really negates a lot of the pressure of
this LightSquared Bishop plays on the
square on f7 but all in all I played
rook to d7 I don't know that's a lot
worse but I just do prefer just to
finding with my pawns letting my major
pieces play more of an active role
instead of just defending but then we
see the knight come up here to e5 and
this is another opportunity to see how
many arrows I can get on board we see
the bishop Knight and Queen all
attacking this and only the rook in the
King you never want your King to be one
of the pieces that's defending a very
very important square on the board and
so we see the Queen come up here to c7
to try to defend this and then we see
rook over here to d1 attacking the rook
putting more pressure and then we're
cover here to e7 there's just not a ton
of great options on board you can see
rook here to e7 you could also maybe see
rook over here to d8 that's kind of the
only options that he has he decides for
rook here to e7 a Bishop to f7
he kind of has to take with the rook if
he says King to h8 that all of a sudden
Knight to g6 pawn takes Queen over here
to h4 that is going to be checkmate so
he correctly decides I need to go ahead
and take that with my rook on f7 but
then the Queen takes the Queen takes
then the knight takes and then the
bishop comes down here if you were to
take with his King here on f7 then all
of a sudden rook up here d7 after the
King moves the bishops going to fall and
then this rook is very active starting
to attack these pawns on the board we do
see a similar state after the bishop
comes down here then the rook takes the
King comes here to f7 rook up here to d7
after the King moves then the rook comes
over here to be
seven so if we look at both sides of the
board Bobby Fischer has a slight
advantage
rooks definitely play better at the end
of the game together than just a bishop
in a rook black does have one extra pawn
but they are on different sides of the
board it's going to be difficult to kind
of hang on to all the pressure Bobby
Fischer can really put on his opponent
well black needs to do is start pushing
these pots that's his really only way to
win this he's not going to overpower him
with his pieces a Bobby Fischer he has
two main objectives one is to make sure
these pawns don't push forward the
second one is to start to exchange some
of these pawns on the board and then
just put more pressure on his opponent
on the kingside where that he can either
trade off some of these materials and
get advantage with his pawns or just
have a passed pawn that he could start
to push forward on the Kings side but
he's gassed Spassky starts out with rook
to a 1 check King to h2 Bishop to d6 so
being fairly aggressive Bishop here d6
pawn here to g3 and then pawn to b4 so I
sold pawn chain here I'm being protected
by the bishop as well so then Bobby
Fischer decides to get to work so King
to g2 pawn h5 rook here to b6 and this
does stop the bishop from really moving
anywhere since it is being tied down to
the king room over here to d1 getting
ready to play rook to d5 which i think
is a really good defensive move a king
to f3 and then King up to f7 and I don't
really like this move I you know getting
your King away from the action I don't
think is the plan I get that the bishop
is tied down to it you may want this
bishop to get more involved than it is
right now but rook up here to d5 makes
way more sense than get his King a
little bit more aggressive if he wants
to he does have some protection with his
rook involved but King over here to e2
attacking the rook now the rule comes to
d5 I think it's a little bit too late
pawn to f4 pawn to g6 for some reason
buddy Spassky wants to attack on the
Kings side it's not going to go that
well after the exchange on board pawn to
g5 upon to f5 and now we do see a passed
pawn on the F file for white to go ahead
and start to attack Bishop to e5 and
then rook to b5 really nice defense from
Bobby Fischer as far as these pawns
can't move anywhere
if this pawn moves the rooks going to
fall off this pawn
the pond just going to fall so really
but a spassky's kind of in a tough spot
he decided to play King to f6 but then
rook over here to be for the pond can't
recapture this was the the sole pawn
defending the squaring or else the rook
would fall so Bobby Fischer just
gobbling up material right here
Bishop down here to d4 that's nice
little outposts not really doing too
much on the board rook to b6 attacking
the king king up here to f3 and this is
a nice square because the bishop can't
attack it now the route can't attack it
either so it's a very safe square for
the King and also just more aggressive
on board from Bobby Fischer rook up here
to d8 would like to get behind his
opponent maybe bring it over here to
this first rank right here Bobby
Fischer's not having any of it though
rook up here b8 says hey if you want
exchanged on board that's going to be
fine with me I'll have a rook you have a
bishop I can start to push this pawn up
the board you can't really stop me a
rook to b7 says hey let's go in exchange
work here to b6 but it's basky says okay
I'm kind of tired of doing this rook to
be 7 or d7 and that's exactly what Bobby
Fischer wants that can bring his rook
over here to g6 attacking this pawn and
then after King to a d5 rook g5 Bobby
Fischer is just annihilating this in
game he's taken to the pawns on the
Kings side in exchange for one of his
pawns and taking one the pawns over here
on the Queen side and but he's fatzke
hasn't even moved his pawns early on he
just played pawn to be forward solidify
the pawn chain and that was it nothing
else has happened except Bobby Fischer's
kind of run over him Bishop here to e5
pawn up here to f6 saying hey nice try
but now you can't take this pawn because
your Bishop is being pinned down to the
King King down here to a d4 rook to B 1
and then we after this rook to b1 this
is the game but these baski decides to
go ahead and resign everyone always ask
me it can you go through some of the
variations of what might happen if the
bishop moves here well it's it's
definitely lost calls well they're all
kind of lost causes but rook here to f5
doesn't really matter where the rook or
the bishop moves to then the rook is
going to fall rook down here to d1 check
and then this rooks going to fall
because the bishops not a light square
it can't protect
this rook if for some reason we say
instead of the vision of taking let's
say rook to you know f7 let's try to put
more pressure on this we don't want this
pawn to push any further on the board
then all of a sudden rook to a d1 the
King doesn't have tons of great options
because we talked about for this King on
f3 is a great square blocking off a lot
of the squares the King can go to so
once the King moves all of a sudden the
rook to e5 taking that bishop this pawn
it's going to be going as well and
there's too much pressure for for bobby
fisher' so he is now up three games
after 10 games after giving up the first
two so congratulations to Bobby Fischer
in at game 10 I think one of the most
exciting matches or games in this whole
match that we've had really really crazy
lines that you don't see very often
Bobby Fischer in the in game played some
of the best in game chess I have ever
seen hopefully you guys enjoyed this
exciting game and I will see you guys in
game number 11 thanks for watching